the battlefield one winner update is
full of new features and tweaks and it's
coming very very soon I'm Tony this is a
game spot news update and for more
first-person action make sure to
subscribe the biggest new additions to
the game our ribbons there are a total
of twenty each based on completing
certain tasks with weapons or vehicles
earn one during a match and you'll get a
nice chunk of XP new icons and dog tags
are also on the way and Max class ranks
are going from 10 all the way up to 50
the other big changes are on the server
side you can vote on the map and game
type while playing on rented servers and
admins will be able to kick or ban
problematic players this all comes on
top of the usual weapon balancing and
bug fixes battlefield ones winter update
starts rolling out on all platforms on
Tuesday februari 14 for more first
person shooter talk check out our
discussion on Tom Clancy games on the
lobby gamespot's weekly live show every
wednesday at 11am pacific and to keep up
with all the biggest battlefield news
you're already in the right place
you